does any of this noise sound familiar to
you they want a constitutional right to
block me is it revenge to say get that
son of a doctor field such poor
leadership ability but then Trump quote
pay dearly calling him up all this noise
you heard all of it none of its going
away not a single one of its going to
it's just gonna be a different story a
month from now six months from now 12
months from now five years from now by
the way on top of all this noise you
heard you're gonna have noise about who
you marry your faith your career path
whether you choose to become an
entrepreneur whether you say I want to
make six figures all of a sudden you
start making seven figures they'll say
money is important to your friends we'll
talk behind your back if you're worth a
hundred million dollars oh my gosh this
guy's so full of it if you become a
billionaire you know what they'll say
they'll say he's disconnected from the
average life but whatever you ever do
there's gonna be the snow so one of the
things I had to lure talked me years to
learn this thing was this you have to
understand that the noise if you aspire
to become bigger like the noise is gonna
get louder and more people you got to
turn off all the noise let them keep
speaking because they're just promoting
you turn off all the noise and do what
you need to do today to execute your
game plan and eventually you'll realize
that the only time noise will stop is
when you die it's the only time it ain't
never stop until the day we die